how do you get people to engage with you
on social media now this is a question
that I got in Maria I got wow I'm
military this is a question I got from
our rate in my mastermind group and if
the master who is called TGIM because we
meet on Mondays and it's tuesday at
midnight so i guess technically is
wednesday i am crazy light and answering
this maria i apologize i had been
working through the acquisition of a
company and bringing on a new team and
last night I didn't get the bed till
type in the morning and it's midnight I
just finished another meeting with
somebody about this new idea and I'm
like I me to make this video for Maria
because I promised her so excuse me if
I'm a little tired my voice is little
crack from talking for so long but we're
here this is important Maria is doing a
lot of stuff on periscope and she is
running these live chats and she is
finding wine she's getting a lot of
people to come to the chats but she's
not getting a lot of engagement
afterwards they're saying hi to her but
they're not asking questions afterwards
I want my feedback on how to get better
so Maria here's Madison for you I got
three tips I want to go over first is
have a regular schedule and what I find
I'm not going to log in these twitter
chats on Google Hangouts when you have a
regular schedule it's easy for people to
want to come back to and stick with so I
know you're doing at eleven o'clock at
night on certain days I don't know that
every day I don't know that's one thing
wednesday friday i don't know if that's
weekends you want to have a consistent
schedule so that people know when they
come to have an amazing chat with maria
and gets an awesome feedback to help
them grow their business or live a
better life or whatever you're talking
about and so I would set that out and at
the end of your your chat then the next
one you promote and you say hey tomorrow
again eleven o'clock or next wednesday
at eleven o'clock come join me so you
start creating the system as scheduled
people put in their calendars and know
and they come to expect it so i have a
regular schedule the second thing is
have things i don't know what you talk
about in your periscope chats but i find
it super helpful to get discussions
happening when you have a set theme for
each one and so the twitter chats that i
run a successful
we've been a part of Maria the Google
Hangouts I might have been successful
because they all have a theme where I
find it you just open it up and say hey
what do you want to talk about a lot of
times people don't know what they want
to talk about and so they don't they
don't ask a question they'll sit there
on the watch and they'll hope to gain a
little bit of knowledge from you but
they won't think about what they want to
ask where if you primed them and you
give them ideas if you're you know
you're going to talk about how to market
your business you're going to talk about
how to have success with periscope
you're going to talk about how to create
a YouTube video you're going to talk
about how to live a better life you're
going to talk about your morning routine
whatever it is if you have a set theme
for each one then it gets people
thinking about questions that they want
to ask around those set themes where
ever again if it's too loosey-goosey and
just free-for-all then it's harder for
people to come up with questions because
you haven't climbed them music here's a
great example where I find this holds a
lot of on kotaku growing their business
in terms of getting new referrals people
say I need referrals in referrals and
referrals my company where if you aren't
specific with the type of referral that
I need then it's hard for me to help you
you know if you're just a web developer
right i know tons of web developers so
why am i going to refer someone to you
versus somebody else where have you said
i'm looking for clients as a web
developer who are who are in the
financial space as an example i love
working with banks or i love working
with insurance companies or love working
with companies of a certain size then
that starts immediately me thinking
about what financial companies do I know
what banks do I know right it starts
immediately shaping my mind towards that
topic or if you just said web design
it's so general that I don't think about
it and it goes over my head and so a tip
for entrepreneurs is when you're asking
for help you want to be specific because
as soon as you start saying those words
specific words it aligns people's brain
to start finding solutions for you you
want people to ask you questions have
set themes that gears our brain towards
those topics naturally before I lost my
train of thought quickly i'm watching my
wife she's here playing league of
legends
love you baby she's focused she's in the
zone now pay attention to me it's hard
because I'm talking so much and very
loudly oh you pay attention she looked
at me she's focused she's intend I'm the
game alright moving on um so have a
regular schedule have regular themes
next is I would ask them questions and a
lot of times what you have to watch out
for in a chat or in any kind of these
live hangouts is sometimes people expect
the comment just to listen a lot of
times people will watch a hanging out
with me and just expect to listen to
take in to absorb knowledge to hear from
me or if I'm interviewing somebody
throat is killing me to hear their
feedback are the questions that I'm
asking them they don't necessarily
realize that they can ask a question as
well they can get their feedback from
that question and so what I always do is
as much as possible try to have a way
for people to ask questions first of all
in advance so if I'm doing a Twitter
chat I'll put out the hashtag and let
them know hey ask the question with this
hashtag you know answer it on the
Twitter check if i have a google hangout
schedule i'll have on the sidebar to say
hey if you have any questions for me or
my guest leaving him here will answer it
for for you during the show and so
people start asking questions already
and then when we start the programs
already some free questions that i can
answer and against people are in
thinking 20 evidence and ask evan is
answering questions Maria's answering
questions maybe I could throw in my own
question and while you're answering
somebody's else's question they're
thinking about the question that they
can answer that sorry that they can ask
themselves and so I would definitely be
looking at a way to let people know that
you want to answer question so I'd be
saying hey you guys have questions let
me know and then start answering
people's questions already because
you've lined the few of them up does
that make sense so whatever makes sense
in terms of periscope if you want people
to tweet with a certain hashtag or email
you a question or whatever it is you
want to have a few free questions
already set up and lined up from people
so that when you start the chat it's not
you going on a monologue it's a QA and
then people know that hey I ask my
question
going to answer ok Maria those are my
three tips for you hopefully it helps so
looking over it again have a regular
schedule so I know exactly when you're
going to be online every time have
themes and topics for each chapter
you're doing and then let them find the
way or you should find a way to have
three questions and then make sure that
you are asking for their questions
during the chat I apologize as I did at
the start from my maybe lack of focus
and my tiredness at the moment it's been
a crazy crazy crazy but exciting past
couple of days I still have a little bit
more to do it's coming up on 1230 in the
morning but your passion to drive you
and so I believe thank you guys for
watching thank you everybody in the
mastermind group I will see you again on
Monday and continue to believe